the burgeoning scandal involving
congressman eric swalwell and a honey
trap that is a suspected chinese spy who
used her
charms to get close to the congressman
and various other elected officials is
probably just the beginning
of what could be a huge story involving
beijing's espionage efforts here in the
united states
former cia officer dan hoffman says
there are likely thousands of operations
like the one that targeted swalwell
and the horny midwestern mayors
it's extraordinarily diverse and
ubiquitous if you think about
chinese intelligence officers they're
operating in washington dc and at the
consulates in san francisco and new york
and chicago and los angeles they use
all sorts of collectors and some very
creative ways of stealing our secrets
they are
you know ruthlessly focused on
conducting espionage in this country
and china's fear of influence in america
is coming into sharper focus hollywood
big
tech multinational corporations
professional leagues the nba
lebron james remember that and even
american colleges as we have seen
all facing new scrutiny over examples of
them bending to beijing's will why
money who knows what else uh but dana
are you afraid ever
i mean some of my uh our friends erica
and my friends
uh asian uh worry about uh racism
you know isn't that a concern as we
are we're legitimately concerned about
the big issue of espionage and
stealing secrets yeah and i think that
sure and we have to be aware of it i
mean we knew what happened as soon as um
to some people of asian descent um and
just a few of the reported cases when uh
the covet first started
of them being targeted and attacked of
course nobody wants that but i do think
this
um america has been given a wake-up call
in this small well thing now
maybe he um didn't realize maybe that he
was being duped
and then he when he found out he
cooperated with authorities and look
okay like let's just talk about that but
his explanations here to now
have not really been very good and
they're trying to distract by
saying that well kevin mccarthy on the
republican side needs to deal with q and
on
okay maybe fine but actually can we go
back to the subject
at hand because you're not answering any
of those questions
and these questions continue into the
senate races in georgia
john ossoff one of the democrats that's
running has had to amend his financial
disclosure because
his documentary film company after
remember he ran for the house
made a ton got a ton of money to run for
that race didn't win
after that all of a sudden this chinese
communist
media company out of hong kong that was
basically very much against the protest
started donating
or funding this documentary film company
and david perdue the senator that is
challenging him said
you need to make that right you need to
be honest about that and transparent
about it
and also i've had to amend his
financial dealings i've got to tell you
if you look at
who do they target up-and-coming young
progressive people
you know if i were in georgia i'd take a
look
that's why no one has ever targeted me
because i'm
not young or progressive anyway uh
greg you're your best big picture what
are we looking at here what's the
what is why does this matter to mom and
pop america that china is stealing uh
these secrets so they buy from china
they buy stuff cheaper
well i um i think we could safely say
that honey pots are bad look what they
did to winnie the pooh
um i you know when you look at this
story
when you look at this story i want you
to i want you to see this venn diagram
all right you have two sets in this venn
diagram in one set
trump haters and the other set people
beholden to china
if you look at within each set it's
hollywood nba
academia big tech and media they're in
the same
these are the same people the same exact
people
there has to be a connection that trump
bothers them because it
impacts their relationship with china
now i want to
also talk about what drives so many
people to disagree with trump
it's because they hate him and so they
end up making these ridiculous decisions
like this like like being okay with a
country that has concentration camps
and i'm wondering like how much of their
lives are dictated by their
irrational hatred of trump did they stop
eating oranges
do they no longer sun tan did they give
up golf
do they boycott people named donald i
mean these are people that are
essentially changing their lives
because of this irrational hatred for
somebody who reminds them of a boss they
didn't like
you know jesse is swalwell just a dope
uh you know uh he it just seems like
such
i i couldn't i the reason he got no
votes is that
everyone looked at him and saw nothing
home
geraldo if i was a member of congress i
would assume
every woman trying to sleep with me was
trying to compromise me
her name was fang fang she was a chinese
national
she was bundling money for him that
didn't set off any alarm bells to
swalwell
house intel guy has he watched a movie
before
if he's really in love with her maybe
have someone tailor to see if she goes
to the consulate
have your intel guys run her name
through the system see if anything comes
up
then maybe you could dip your toe in but
seriously you're just gonna trust
someone like this
they have programs in washington for
congressmen
to tell them hey these are some of the
things you need to look out for
i think pelosi sponsored him remember he
beat pete stark out in california's this
young
gun she put him on house intel then he
screwed up she's embarrassed
he made a fool out of himself he made a
fool out of her so she doesn't want to
show weakness
and and cut him down but geraldo you
nailed it right at the top it's about
money
this is a country china 1.5 billion
people
our company's salivating over that kind
of market those are revenues for
centuries
nike apple wall street
so they just look the other way
they donate to democrats who are soft on
china
and they get their way trump comes along
and says hey guys we got to slap tariffs
on them
and that rocked the boat and he needed
to go
isn't part of the problem or a big part
of the problem judge that politics is
is such a voracious consumer of money
no no politics is as clean or as dirty
as you want it to be
look this guy goes from city council and
with the help of fang fang
ends up in the uh and congress and then
a minute later thinks he should run for
president
while swearing to the american people
that president trump is a russian asset
i mean you know where does he get this
kind of hutzpa at the end of the day
what makes him think he should run for
president where is all this hate coming
from
where is the support coming from look
and for nancy pelosi to come out and say
everybody knew everybody knew mccarthy
says i never knew no one told me
but as soon as swalwell knew the woman
disappeared
why did she disappear who told her to
disappear
there's a lot more in this story i'm
telling you you think he tip
do you think you tipped her off don't
know
that'll be the cliffhanger